من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه ينضم الينا للحديث
عن هذا التطور
ما الذي يجري في المنطقه برايك ولماذا
ارسلت هذه الغواصه الى الشرق الاوسط
حسن قد يكون فعلا هناك تهديدات ايرانيه
ولكن حتى الان هذه التهديدات لا ترقى الى
مستوى هذا الرد يعني القصف على القوات
الامريكيه في سوريا والرد الامريكي عبر
غاره جويه هو مختلف تماما من ان تاتي هذه
الغواصه يعني اليوم نحن نتحدث عن المنطقه
كمنطقه عن التحولات الكبرى عن موضوع كان
لامريكا السيطره والهيمنه في يعني منطقه
الخليج الاسطول الخامس منطقه البحر
المتوسط الاسطول السادس المناورات
المشتركه ايران الصين روسيه في بحر عمان
المناورات المشتركه في جنوب افريقيا الصين
وروسيه ويقال انه
السفينه غورسكو فسد في مرفا على المحيط
على البحر الاحمر وكانه اليوم هناك تحدي
كبير لهيمنه امريكا البحريه على هذه
المناطق في ثلاث ممرات بحريه السويس
المندب
وهذا يعتبر شيء مهم جدا جدا للبحريه
الامريكيه بشكل عام
يعني يعني
ماذا تقصد هنا بالضبط هل هي مجرد نوع من
الاستعراض لابراز القوه ام ان هناك فعلا
ما يخطط للايام القادمه على المستوى
العسكري
على المستوى العسكري حسن لا يعني هذه
السفينه او هذه الغواصه هي قادره على شان
حرب هي قادره على شان عمليات او غاره
بواسطه التوماهوك ذات المدى 2500 كيلو متر
هي عمليه عرض عضلات وضع الردع وتثبيت
الوضع على ان هذه المنطقه هي منطقه
امريكيه
نستذكر منذ سنوات حسن انها كانت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عندما كانت تريد ان
ترسل رساله كانت القذيفه الاستراتيجيه ذات
قدرات النوويه البي فيكت تو تحلق فوق
منطقه الخليج يرافقها طيران من دول الخليج
ليوم الواقع هذا كله تبدل هذا الامر يزيد
معنى الردع بابعاد متعدده
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي احدثتنا من بيروت